so we started from my typical spawn
points of beers and you six it's like
protagonists it we have a two factions
one of one we called the United security
it's pro-west pro-europe pro-western yep
is very Pro Weston private military
company and russian beer will on this
exact location we have a have a purpose
to have a goal so get out alive from
this exact location and transfer to
factory location and the this open-world
location called rate have it has lots of
things it's lots of secret places lock
doors and stuff just to make the game
more you know explorable and mmm and
interesting in terms of finding some
cool stuff and reaching some unreachable
places and finding some cool stuff there
keep your how's it going can you tell us
please enemy contact right he would give
up on demand for rifle and George George
said that he encountered some enemies so
it's better to take a self help them
looks like a battle situation is
changing and the they got some guys they
dropped them and some of some of them
are going through there Oh citizen block
pick up check up on this key just in
green is not the dormitory we have a
fully concealed city with visit suburbs
yeah and locations
the TV city block blocked with UN forces
and Russian military forces and you know
it's quite a song with the villa borders
consists of snipers and minefields you
too we have to get out with on the light
so the main idea and the main idea of
tar often naming of a game it's escaping
try to escape from jargon for life and
when you try to do it you will see how
many mysteries and tasks you need to
solve it's not just the only it's not
just about the survival it's more like
human relations between many mercenaries
and the local guys like scavengers as I
said before we have a three-floor to
block to block two buildings of a city
citizen citizen apartments and every
single room is fully searchable unglue
double so every single drawer you can
open it you can break it and you can
pick the clock later pick lock and even
if you have a key can buy this key from
a trader later and get into this
location and open this door with the
with this key so there is lots of room
to lots of places to be searched the
research you during the rate you you can
you can take many ways to complete the
rate you can move freely and try to make
your own wrote route so take some
adventures can go antigen can click and
click the red really fast it's depends
on your knowledge of location and your
tactical abilities like weapons and gear
I'm here Josh hit some top scavenger
melo's nice one escape from Shaq off
weekends I seem simply from a one bullet
the kids sure you can get hit in the
stomach with a single bullet and bleed
bleed out to death and there's a there's
a lots of different way to know to die
let's get out of here what's going on
what's going to chop her head you can he
will just kill Jorah George he said the
judge will betray but he take the exit
first include this and this location you
have a prerequisite that tells you that
there is a nuts a good option to kill
your friends to kill your pmcs or even
that's your pc or just every pmc
operator and you will receive some
minuses in karma and if you have a low
karma you will get some strange stuff
like you are going to be sick for no
reason even you're going through
take more dams okay Cuba is dropped and
i think this is our first session and
we're going to stop nest we're going to
stop this exact session